[Music]
whether he is the most famous artist on
the planet you know that I'm sure people
would you know dispute that and would
name other names but he I mean he is a
global superstar he was just such a
brilliant painter he broke rules that
haven't been broken for centuries you
know and he did it his way he kind of is
a bit like the tortured rock stars Kurt
Cobain or Jimi Hendrix and and he has
that sort of rock star up here
we appreciate him for his struggle for
his energy for his emotion for his
belief he believed in himself
[Music]
everybody has a different story
that what happened to him he was a nice
quiet man
no is skulking about then he comes here
with a girl who I reckon was out of his
league and the next thing I hear he's
killed himself
this film is history in the making
the world's first ever fully painted
feature film exploring the tortured life
and mysterious death of one of the
world's greatest ever artists Vincent
van Gogh he was mad he was an
interesting man he was a genius
starring Chris O'Dowd Saoirse Ronan and
Douglas booth it quite literally brings
to life some of his most inspirational
works rather than using computers to
digitally animate it all sixty four and
a half thousand frames have been
laborious ly painted the vision of an
oscar-winning director and his wife I've
done a lot of computer animation if I
thought I could get the same look of oil
painting moving before your eyes in the
computer I would have probably done it
in the computer because this I wouldn't
have gone to all the trouble of finding
124 painters in three different
countries setting up you know three
studios to achieve this and do it so
painstakingly by Handel
that they actually move each brushstroke
frame by frame unless I thought it could
come up with a look which you couldn't
achieve any other way despite their
relatively small budget the filmmakers
managed to get a stellar cast onboard
who bought into the project and perhaps
it's no surprise when this is the
closest they'll ever get to having their
portrait painted by Van Gogh I've never
worked on anything quite like this and I
probably won't ever again because it's
not like an animation where you just
turn up and you do your voice and you go
away it's a performance that you put in
and you then there's there's two artists
there's the actor and there's the
painter and you both work to bring it to
life although I actually they've put in
a lot more work than I do
I did what did that nobody ever do for
us you see each brush stroke you see it
has a texture to it I believe under
other animations however great don't
have because it's been done by hand we
paint sixty two thousand four hundred
and fifty paintings and to do that we
need a lot of painters and behind each
of these black curtains we have a
painter the film is five years in the
making involving more than a hundred
unbelievably talented
dedicated artists from all over the
world so this is the Aegean who's done
more shots on the film than anyone else
how long is this shots 4 seconds yeah
that's 98 frames so he does a quarter or
a third of a second each day so
something like 20 days just for that one
shot of the car going through with the
women
most days I do about 6 to 7 frames what
you have to do is get the movement
believable and the other thing that
happens and I'm really bad at this is
that I'll move the face and I'll forget
to move say the hairline so a face looks
like she's shifting and a hair stays the
same so if you have to concentrate the
whole time is quite the antithesis of
the high-tech studio you might expect
for a feature animation there are three
studios the lead here in Poland where
they're using an unprecedented process
to take each frame filmed using actors
and paint over every single one of them
basically those four stages the earliest
stage which is shooting it against blue
screen with actors and then putting a
reference over that this is for the
painters to make it easy for them to
paint and this bit was the final result
this is Douglas booth and and
Christopher how's your Postal Service
can't find him what makes you think I
can just use your initiatives on an
important man like mr. T or van gock ask
around what do I say when I find him
it's amazing what the paint picks up and
what these what these artists have have
been managed to do with just even the
tiny micro expressions it was also fun
to go and meet a bunch of painters that
for two years have just been painting
your face
glad to see you're honoring God not like
your friend mum
Barbara's friend we cover around 130
original Vincent van Gogh paintings in
the film and bring those to life and 60
minutes of the film is in Vincent
Technicolor and the flashbacks are in
this very nice black and white style
visually loving Vincent will undoubtedly
blow audiences away but at the heart of
any great movie are the characters and
the plot and Van Gogh SMAP knows his
genius not to mention the mystery
surrounding his death were a gift for
the script writers working on this film
Vincent died on the 29th of July 1890
from gunshot wounds to the chest and
more than 125 years on there's still
speculation over whether it was suicide
or even murder
it's these conflicting accounts of his
last days that caught the imagination of
the filmmakers of loving Vincent why he
would kill himself when he was just
succeeding for the first time in eight
years so for eight years he'd been
struggling
he'd had many knockbacks and then in the
year of his death he had brilliant
reviews and also money declared him the
most exciting new artist and he seemed
to be cured he wasn't drinking as much
anymore and yet six weeks later his dead
I think it's the tragedy you know in the
sorrow because we can all relate to that
you know why do we love soap operas so
much because we see something within us
of the poor person that that's in the
script but interestingly enough some
people don't think that van Gogh was the
greatest painter they think it was a
brilliant painter but perhaps not the
greatest but it's the story it's
all-encompassing did he cut off his
earlobe and give it to a prostitute as a
gift you know there's so many
medicine and stories
van Gogh was born here in the
Netherlands in 1853 and its capital
Amsterdam has become the focal point for
fans to pay homage to perhaps the
country's greatest export he didn't
become an artist until his late 20s and
in the following ten years produced
nearly 900 paintings
most in the last two years before he
died and the myth thing he only actually
sold one during his lifetime the van
Gogh Museum is visited by nearly two
million people every year and holds the
largest and most important collection of
his paintings in the world
200 of his oil paintings are on show
here the bulk from the last few years of
his life in France which were not only
his most productive but also his most
troubled this vast collection gives a
fascinating insight into the
extraordinary personality behind the
arts as well as some of his techniques
Vincent painted over 30 self-portraits I
believe and what does that say about him
as a man I mean what kind of a character
was saying
Vincent himself he had a very stubborn
personality but that stubbornness on the
one hand didn't really endear him
necessarily to people around him but on
the other hand it also meant that he was
a very stubborn artist you know he
pursued his calling if you like you know
also in a very stubborn way in a very
disciplined way but that made after all
that he in a very short period of 10
years you know created this enormous
amount of work and created this enormous
legacy the museum also holds 400
drawings and 700 letters many written to
his beloved little brother Theo
who was Vincent's biggest supporter both
emotionally and financially and give a
unique understanding into the mind of a
genius his trials and tribulations he
shares in his letters with his brother
with with friends but mostly with his
brother and he really does talk about
the challenges that he experiences both
as an artist but also in his daily life
and the loneliness that he experienced
and experiences and the fact that he is
feels misunderstood also later on in his
career his frustration that he is not
breaking through as an artist that
people don't understand his work that
they that he doesn't sell of course you
know that is sort of a burden for him it
was the last letter Vincent wrote to his
brother a week before his death that
inspired the film he wrote we cannot
speak other than by our paintings
and this is exactly what the filmmakers
wanted to do to tell the story of Van
Gogh through his own work
letting the paintings tell his story
loving Vincent is a groundbreaking film
fully painted by a team of more than a
hundred artists over a period of five
years it tells the story of Vincent van
Gogh through his own paintings
it's a painted animation which means we
shoot it like a normal movie they then
project every frame of the movie onto a
canvas and then artists paint over over
each frame in the style of Van Gogh
in his lifetime he was so unappreciated
people didn't you know he wasn't
celebrated he was he felt like he wasn't
very good but he was desperate to be an
artist and he just worked and worked at
it and I think to all artists that
appeals people that are afraid to go
into an art gallery because they feel
intimidated that want to find out more
about the man himself or really love
this film because it's almost like
sitting talking to him you know you hear
him come alive through his paintings the
paintings have sounds they have words
it's like watching poetry about him
filmmakers came here to the van Gogh
Museum in Amsterdam to gain an insight
into this great painters work his life
and his techniques van Gogh's tragic
life his struggle with depression the
fact that he cut off his own ear and
committed suicide are as famous as these
self-portraits
but this film asked the question did he
actually shoot himself or was it in fact
murder and attempts to reflect the man
behind the madness the thing that really
amazed me about Vincent was that he had
actually failed for careers and was the
black sheep of the family and completely
depressed and alone when he was 27 years
old and he turned himself from someone
who everyone had written off as a nobody
a nonentity an unpleasant person into
them probably the the most famous artist
in history this is the famous house that
Vincent rented in all in the late 1880s
on which he described in detail to his
brother Theo in his letters and this is
perhaps one of his most famous of
paintings his bedroom and these
paintings along with his letters give an
incredible insight into Vincent van Gogh
slice and also his state of mind
so the backdrop to these masterpieces is
an enthralling and tragic story of a
loner plagued by mental illness who
never got to enjoy his own success the
beginning of the end for Vincent came
when he cut off his ear the point at
which his illness began to take over he
was sort of losing his facilities that
he was not in control of himself anymore
it may have led to hallucinations
we know from descriptions at the time
that he also then had to be restrained
because he started to eat paint
he felt he needed to commit himself to
an institution to the asylum and Santa
me where he actually volunteer Elise
admitted himself because he felt he was
no longer in control
one theory that's been discredited is
the idea that van Gogh madness fueled
his artistic genius
on the contrary Vincent made his best
work when lucid there is this perceived
notion that he was just mad and he was
just crazy and that you know he was just
crazily flinging paint at the canvas and
was sort of out of control and that is
something that is patently not true I
think we need to divorce the art that he
made the paintings that he created from
his illness because he made them almost
despite of his illness rather than
because of it
here we have all of our paintings drying
so this is from the fight put them in
the rain this one here this is actually
based upon the original painting of
Armand droolin to somehow reflect van
Gogh genius the filmmakers needed
exceptionally talented artists who would
not only be able to replicate his work
but would also be able to animate it it
was very hard to convince them to paint
in different style they have to paint a
couple of shots to get this and then
they just like machines you know they
play like Bangkok I think the the
biggest problem is that you have to
scratch it off and then you just like
you paint amazing painting and you are
so happy about this it looks like van
Gogh painting and then you just have to
scratch it you have to be very patient
so when you are an artist you think that
you are the best and that your work is
super great and then somebody told you
that now you have two changes and you
have to scratch it or you have to delete
frames and then you have to struggle
with yourself and your ego actually so
that is that's the dress the white bit
of the dress and then that's the dress
shadow we work really hard we work long
long hours we do sort of 9 10 hour days
and sometimes the animation doesn't work
as well as it should and you'll be told
to delete it and start again so that's
sort of having a workup up for such
intense criticism is it's quite sort of
it's not belittling or anything that's
humbling that's what reminds me of Van
Gogh really we're sort of in his
footsteps
[Music]
I became faster I was always a slow
painter but now because you have to pay
fast so you learn how to be kind of
really concentrated and then just paint
we need to be really patient because of
course we're not we're not machines
many have uprooted their lives to base
themselves here in Poland for months if
not years
utterly dedicated to learning Vincent's
style I've worked in foreign eight
months eight and that's it now no more
you're going home yes I want to go home
to my children to rest and best thing
that's ever happened to me
sometimes I hate it sometimes I love it
it's like a roller coaster yeah it's
been fun all the way and exciting
[Music]
when an unofficial trailer was leaked on
Facebook the response was staggering
attracting over a hundred million views
within weeks
it just went mad and I just I saw it
popping up on my Facebook feed it was
all my friends they didn't even know I
was in it going have you seen this this
is amazing was I actually a minute I
haven't actually had a so much interest
in the movie I've made from my peers and
people my age ever that everyone thinks
it's the coolest thing ever there are
few films where the filmmaking process
is as fascinating as the film itself but
that is certainly the case here opening
shot of the film we descend from starry
night down over I'll pass the yellow
house and into the the famous night cafe
and that's shot is 1,250 frames which
meant we had to do 625 paintings and
because it was a moving shot they pretty
much had to do a new painting each time
so we had three painters working on that
shot for over six months we have
definitely without a doubt invented the
slowest form of filmmaking ever devised
in 120 years starry starry night
paint your palette blue and gray I
imagined you would love to know that all
these years later a hundred artists who
really are completely inspired by him by
putting this work into his story shadows
on the heels
sketch the trees and the daffodils I
just hope that he's watching from his
art studio on the cloud and thinking
yeah we actually appreciate him now he
saw beauty in everything be it sunrise
or a sunset or some flower colors
changing you his art his life his life
story the drama the perceived drama of
his life and the miss that has arisen
you know that makes for justice you know
global icon that he is nowadays what I
love that you can see he humans they
heat the human touch to it it's not it's
not perfect because the brushstrokes are
changing the whole time so it feels
alive and the pain is alive and when you
had it on that on that scale and the
cinema screens can I hooked me quite
quite magical
perhaps this
for they could not love you in a world
where everything seems to be going
digital and so many decisions are driven
by saving time and money the choice to
spend years painstakingly painting tens
of thousands of canvases seems about
more than just authenticity this is a
labor of love and proof there are some
things modern technology just can't
capture and when no hope was left inside
on that starry starry night you took
your life as lovers often do but I could
have told you Vincent this world was
never meant for one is beautiful
you
[Music]